rock et métal donc dans le set suite
avec christophe et manu à ma droite et
eric et fred à ma gauche donc bon soir 4
donc membre du groupe malatesta groupe
fondé en 2000 du côté de rambouillet
c'est un groupe engagé pour la petite
précision et c'est comme ça que j'ai
appris aussi en me renseignant c'est le
nom éponyme d'un révolutionnaire italien
je te malatesta donc c'est un groupe
engagé pourquoi ce choix parce que je
vais quand même préciser aussi que c'est
un anarchiste oui
non en fait c'est vrai que ça répondait
quand même à nos aspirations de l'époque
un bond qui perdure bien évidemment mais
voilà donc on était quand même assez
branché sur cette mouvance politique
entre guillemets beaucoup de
revendications à la d'engagement
politique
en 2007 aujourd'hui si si si mais voilà
on a évolué à ce contexte contexte aussi
social économique a évolué voilà donc on
s'adapte également à tout ça mais non on
garde bien entendu
voilà tout tous les préceptes toutou
toutes ses pensées en fait reste
toujours d'actualité aujourd'hui on sait
comment ça se traduit dans les morceaux
basse et notamment au niveau de
l'écriture des textes et puis bon bah
tout ce qu'on peut mettre en avant aussi
bas dans nos échanges avec d'autres
groupes avec enfin dans les salles dans
lesquelles on peut passer également
voilà il ya des échanges aussi à ce
niveau là et voilà on essaie de tenir la
route avec ce cap
quand on fait du métal du rock métal
dans le département des yvelines c'est
facile comme style musical imposé c'est
pas évident c'est penser par exemple
pour démarcher des scènes aux autres
comment ça se passe pour vous d'une
concrétisation
c'est quoi des a priori on va pas vous
faire passer où il n'y a pas la place
nous ont offert un peu pas en france
c'est plus facile c'est plus facile à
faire passer
et pourtant vous perdurer puisque le
groupe était fondée en 2000 il a évolué
ces dernières années vous avez dit mot
n'étaient pas tous là à la formation du
continent on est moins et manu les seuls
tout à fait les seuls fondateur de
demain la triste tu qui nous vous j'ai
envie de deux ans pourquoi vous les
atouts d'un fou avait vu sa lancée si
mon neveu le désir fait je le connais
depuis plus 15 ans 15 ans 20 ans mais
j'ai remplacé irréaliste et puis on va
regarder un extrait justement de vos
performances le titre s'appelle ne fait
rien
non
une
je suis un
malatesta sur scène ce titre ne fait
rien qu'il en parle un petit peu plus
regardées toi aussi la fin mars lancé
j'ai amené le début du morceau puis et
après nombreux dessus on nous on teste
des partis et après fred a fait le texte
dessus vous travaillez toujours comme ça
toujours composer dans un coin qui après
mon année ce qui dans la veine plein
d'idées voilà terme et mènent chacune
religion qu'on jette ça c'est bon ça
c'est pas bon et puis ça il y en a
d'autres
on adapte les textes dessus après et là
vous préparer le 5ème album we
communiqué de presse on peut lire que
vous préparez des titres rageurs c'est à
dire toujours engagé ce qui change de
ligne
à quoi va ressembler la donne bahia on
reste toujours dans notre mouvance un
petit peu
rock métal avec on va essayer
d'accentuer un petit peu le côté métal
âpre au niveau des textes ou a toujours
cette notion d'engagement qui nous est
cher bien évidemment et on essaie de
conserver parce que c est prépondérant
la partie texte et puis le sens qu'on
donne à ce qu'on fait sortie prévue en
vous en êtes retourné enregistré tout
est enregistré c'est non non non non
vraiment prémices et voilà c'est en
nature le projet pour 2013 on est en
train de boucler enfin les compos un
grand un gros travail au niveau des
compos bien bien caler tout ça et puis
pas d'excès près montre en studio c'est
parti et enregistrés dans le département
des yvelines
pour quelle diffusion ensuite pour ceux
qui ne connaissent pas encore le groupe
et qui voudraient se procurer ensuite
les albums se sera jugé sur quelle
plateforme téléchargement dans les
bretons les changements c'est ça
aujourd'hui le modèle économique avons
parlé des difficultés y aura des cds en
roi décédé à vendre évidemment tous les
dans tous les concerts oui
téléchargements légaux ou une
véritablement et pour vous alors
justement l'objectif c'est quoi ensuite
cette signé sur un label de diffuser
plus appel aux distributeurs aussi vous
démarchez actuellement sur sa liste
rouge lutter on a déjà c'est la deutsche
bank
le label pourquoi vous n'arrivez pas à
le trouver vous vous engagez juste cette
association c'est quoi les difficultés
comment ça se passe concrètement sur le
terrain voilà quand on veut à l'appel du
disque est très très dur si on ne fait
pas la star ac où on venait on ne savait
pas sereine a dit voilà c'est reconnaît
clairement ça fonctionne aussi par là
par le biais d'un du carnet d'adressés
si on n'a pas un carnet d'adressés bien
bien développée avec d'écouter mon
contact
voilà ça clermont ça ça passe pas et
donc si on veut vous découvrir pour
l'instant c'est plutôt sur scène ya
plusieurs dates le 1er décembre du côté
de tours dans les différentes dates
s'affiche times
21h30 tous et 70 là où le samedi
également montigny-le-bretonneux
également renseigné montigny le 19
janvier 2013 contre la semaine prochaine
la scène c'est le meilleur moyen de
découvrir de partager le hard rock
c'est comme les acteurs avec le théâtre
c'est pas c'est pas forcément parce
qu'on fait du hard rock en seine au
niveau de la musique ce pour nous c'est
la scène et les acteurs c'est le théâtre
c'est le raf vraiment rapport à la scène
quel que soit le style de musique
pratiquer un c'est le contact avec le
public au lac s'est complu à tout ce qui
gravite autour de du monde scenic 1 sél
et c'est vraiment intéressant c'est une
approche intéressante et permet
d'enrichir osciller les morceaux je
pense à la préparation de la nourrir la
scène par rapport au studio ça rien à
voir c'est vraiment le moment où on
donne et les mots manquaient et surtout
quand on fait du hard rock on regardera
tout allait encore un petit extrait
juste une dernière question le on
parlait tout à l'heure des difficultés
notamment quand on fait tu auras drogue
ne se produire est ce qu'il ya des
soutiens des structures qui vous
soutiennent je pense aux hauts cris par
exemple le centre de ressources et que
le christ nous soutient énormément
ça se traduit comment ce soutien
justement c'est ça votre conseil stage
voilà tout à fait l'ag préparation
formation au niveau scénique niveau
écriture
placement classement de musicale
management tout ce côté là les aspects
techniques en fait on ne maîtrise pas
nécessairement quand on est amateur et
nous aide vraiment à travailler parce
que d'un point de vue théorique d'un
point de vue pratique
donc ça c'est intéressant et ça ça donne
généralement des déshérités 12 ans tout
à fait malatesta les différentes dates
pour les concerts se sont affichés on va
regarder encore un petit extrait avant
de conclure cet entretien
à la testa donc il sera le groupe sera
en concert dans le département des
yvelines il est à 3 datera à suivre sur
les deux prochains mois est ce que ce
sera trois dates ce sont trois dates
très différente au niveau des morceaux
oui elle était sérieuse le samedi 20
avril en somme en acoustique à l'omnia
aux milles samedi c'est un autre
exercice de style ouais donc on a déjà
fait d'ailleurs un coach rouge et chez
virgin megastore showcase plusieurs
moyens de découvrir donc ce groupe en
acoustique avec beaucoup d'electric
aussi forcément c'est du hard rock merci
à tous les cadres donc respecte revenus
versés dans ce plateau à la journée
mondiale de lutte contre le sida c'est
le 1er décembre on en parlera dans un
instant avec jérôme andré président
d'hachette prévention pardon juste le
temps de revenir sur la loi de
protection du patrimoine oblige les
entreprises à réfléchir à des modes de
transports alternatifs pour leurs
salariés une association à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines leur vient en
aide
les salariés ne le savent peut-être pas
mais les grandes entreprises ont
l'obligation de mettre en place un plan
de déplacement les demandes sont
récurrentes ont fait entre les secteurs
c'est beaucoup au départ c'est des
demandes d'amélioration de l'offre de
transport collectif
après on va sur les modes alternatifs
comme le vélo le covoiturage la marche à
pied et après on verra des questions
beaucoup plus lâches les services parce
qu'il ya comme services à proximité
et au final on travaille sur le logement
qu'est ce qu'on fait les questions de
transport amène des questions de
logement
les gens ont des preuves le transport
parce qu'il avait toujours plus loin
pour des questions de contraintes
immobilière et donc on essaie de
travailler avec les entrées sur les
questions de logement à saint quentin en
yvelines ce principe concerne l'ensemble
des sociétés grandes comme petites une
association est née delta chargée de
réfléchir à ces questions
elle regroupe une quarantaine
d'entreprises et couvre ainsi 50% des
emplois du territoire l'enjeu est
environnemental et économique
car un territoire mieux desservis c'est
un territoire plus attractif sur un
territoire ça permet de pérenniser
l'implantation ça permet de continuer à
recruter et avec
l'augmentation du coût du carburant etc
on se rend compte qu'il est plus en plus
difficile de faire venir des jeunes
s'ils doivent faire l'acquisition d'une
voiture faire des kilomètres et à terme
des entreprises peuvent amener à réduire
leurs effectifs sur cette zone se
développer ailleurs dans des zones qui
rompt plus d'attractivité donc il est
important de penser à long terme exemple
récent mise en place dans ce cadre de
plan de déplacement inter entreprises
la refonte des lignes de bus ski bus
pour mieux desservir la zone de trappes
elancourt seulement 15% des salariés
travaillant à saint quentin en yvelines
utilisent les transports en commun
l'objectif que ce pourcentage gagne un
point par an